two years of red hot housing prices the
market is beginning to cool down here in
southern nevada las vegas realtors
announcing an average price decrease
today the first one we've seen now since
april of 2020. i spoke with a real
estate expert tonight to see what this
means if you're buying or selling
for us
it's kind of a waiting game stewart and
rana timpa are selling their henderson
home it's ready and you love your home
and you're just eager for you know a
nice family
to come you know love this home and
they're also ready to buy hoping to
downsize to a smaller place as they
navigate the ever changing las vegas
real estate market it was about time
after two straight years of skyrocketing
prices las vegas realtors announced a
price decrease on wednesday with the
median price for a single family home in
southern nevada dropping by 2 000
to 480 thousand dollars in june buyers
now have a little bit more options a
little bit more inventory
opportunity to negotiate on price
negotiate on repairs real estate advisor
nick layman calls this a welcome relief
for buyers but some sellers may need to
make adjustments sellers need to be
aware and be a little bit more flexible
that you may have to paint that door you
may have to fix
you know that
garbage disposal that was broken overall
layman hopes this is a sign the market
will soon become a more even playing
field while the tempas hope things even
out for their upcoming move you lower
the price in your house
hopefully you negotiate a better price
when you
buy now lehman says a few things have
caused the housing market to cool off a
rise in interest rates for one along
with the supply of available homes which
he says has nearly doubled in the last
four to six weeks